and just a reminder of our breaking news
this morning the nobel laureate
anti-apartheid activist archbishop
desmond tutu has died at the age of 90.
a statement has been issued on behalf of
the tutu family it says
that in the late 1990s he was diagnosed
with prostate cancer with which he lived
for the past 23 years in recent years he
was hospitalized on several occasions to
treat infections associated with his
cancer treatment and ultimately at the
age of 90 he died peacefully at the
oasis frail care center in cape town
this morning courageous gracious and
concerned for the welfare of others to
the very end that's a statement
on behalf of the tutu family and just to
tell you again desmond tutu south
africa's nobel peace prize winning
activist he was an activist for racial
justice lgbt rights he was also the
retired anglican archbishop of cape town
and he has died this morning in cape
town it was announced by the south
african president cyril ramaphosa he was
an uncompromising foe of apartheid which
of course was south africa's brutal
regime of oppression against the black
majority and he worked tirelessly
nonviolently
for its downfall he was buoyant he was
indeed blunt spoken
um he was a clergyman and he used his
pulpit he was the first black bishop of
johannesburg and later as i said the
archbishop of cape town
so he used his pulpit and frequent
public demonstrations to really
galvanize public opinion against racial
inequality both at home in south africa
and of course globally he was a global
figure archbishop
desmond tutu has died this morning in
cape town at the age of 90. let's speak
to tabe califang he's um the ceo and
founder of brand africa taber thank you
so much for talking to us just tell us
what the archbishop meant
for south africa
for many of us growing up uh in
apartheid south africa in the 70s and
for mainly prior to that he was the
ultimate embodiment of the south african
resistance but more than anything else
he represented the goodness of humanity
he was resilient in his opposition to
apartheid but most importantly he was a
soldier that we needed that apartheid
government couldn't touch because he was
a man of the cloth we've got a picture
um tibet of you actually meeting the
archbishop i think we can get that up
but just tell us what was he like there
you go what was he like
as as a person what was it like being in
his presence
he was uh
there's a few of them there is mandela
there is desmond tutu when you were in
their presence you felt that you were
transcended from the ordinary human
being he was very calm and kind he was
very warm and to to to us he was a
that that is probably the magic of what
what differentiated him from many of the
struggle uh heroes he was not angry he
was a principal so in his presence he
was just a magnanimous human being to be
around her and very warm and very
welcoming and the picture you showed it
was quite late in his uh in his years i
think he was in his 80s already then but
even and he was retired then but even
then uh you were just trans transformed
when you were in his in his presence
because you felt that you're in the
company of somebody greater somebody of
uh above many of
us what has he been doing since he
retired
well he's been inside for many many
years now and uh i think he spent a lot
of time with his beloved wife uh leia
and and he tried to as much as possible
to stay away from the everyday fray of
south africa because
you as you perhaps know very well that
he was not well from uh with
cancer so he needed time to rest this is
the man who had dedicated his life his
life's work his lifetime uh to the
struggle he was out in the streets he
was representing the world but i think
what was so important about him as well
is that uh even even even post his
retirement when something went against
what south africa represented or should
have represented whether it is uh having
to criticize a ruling party of which was
a great supporter he would come out even
during his retirement to make a
statement against it when something that
is the embodiment of who we are uh was
being contradicted he would come out of
retirement to ensure that we will
remember what we've got here and how we
got you and why we are in the
humanitarian goodness of humanity
it's interesting but just putting
pictures of all the people he's met um
and it's it's extraordinary isn't it yes
he was a huge figure within south africa
but
the fact that globally he had um
such a following and just so many people
listened when the archbishop spoke
because he was he was one of those few
people who was not uh who would we never
ever won uh took advantage of his
position in a negative way but everybody
else felt that by being around him they
were also contributing to a greater good
by supporting him yes he loves children
he loved our uh our peoples whether he's
elaborated towards anybody else
everybody wanted to be like him the same
way that he had that similar uh and
nelson mandela are magic of course he
was with us much longer than nelson
mandela because even as a young priest
he was always out there so so his name
and his image was already very global
and uh and he never ever changed i think
what's important about him is that he
never wavered he never changed and the
times never changed it changed him it
remained uh
that which
was a thorn in on the side of apartheid
but not only just apart it the side is
it was the thorn on the side of everyone
who contradicted the goodness of
humanity
that's what i was just about to ask
because um once apartheid fell and
the new south africa was born he was
also a huge critic of corruption wasn't
he
he was uh he would he would stand up
against the ruling party for uh for for
anything against corruption he would
stand up against the ruling party for
when they did
for which he
fought against
okay
thank you so much um thanks a lot for
talking to us where exactly in south
africa are you actually well right now
i'm in lagos i just landed in lagos
he was a pan-african he was a
pan-african so i think it's fitting oh
there you are
thank you so much for talking to us on a
very sad day not only for south africa
but for the world
indeed i appreciate you and he's so rest
in peace he's a good man i will show
that uh how good humanity can be and how
principled one should be when you're
fighting for a good cause he has fought
a good race
indeed thank you